um however to become a debt-free version
we all start that way everyone starts
that way now most women ruin it right
but everybody starts as a debt-free
virgin with no tattoos
um so in one instance everyone becomes
that and in another instance barely
anybody becomes it
um so now palemma says her marketing is
for pedophile and you'll see this
whenever women want to shame men for
liking younger women I did not say
underage women I said younger women
um what they'll do is they'll try to
shame him for it and it's a way for
older women to compete so she's gonna
say you know
um that she's going to imply that
basically an adult can't be a virgin I
can't a 22 year old chick
well it's our poor decisions and poor
choices yet they will continue to blame
it on the mess